Tim Scott the only black Republican
senator currently in the Senate from
South Carolina has announced that he is
running in the Republican primary in
2024 the Associated Press reports
Senator Tim Scott makes it official he's
a republican candidate for president now
we're going to talk about some of the
details here but let me bottom line this
for you the 40 000 foot view on Tim
Scott's candidacy is number one Dead on
Arrival number two how on Earth is the
party that most recently selected as
their candidate an old white guy who
regularly stoked fears about brown and
black people how is that very same
electorate going to say hey you know
what
let's elect a black guy instead of trump
when Trump is actually running again you
don't really need to know anything else
about Tim Scott's candidacy other than
that